[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the title of grand master highly coveted
and sought after since the beginning of
the game
welcome to the third st louis norm
congress
[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
borsch and this is the grand master norm
congress and of course i'm not alone
here we have
mr
and one of the youngest grandmasters of
all time ilya nizhnik hello there hello
ladies and gentlemen um
nice day outside to see you and also we
have to explain what is this norm
congress all about ilya can you tell us
what is a norm well um no no you can't
no i absolutely can
we are done here thank you
okay go ahead let's take two take two
take two well norm what's the norm well
norm is whenever you are proving that
you're worth it to be at a certain level
right so by uh by playing people of
certain level and beating them normally
you you you earn the right to be
at the same level kind of so here we
have
you know two norm events going on where
people can you know play people of
certain levels and grandmas if if you're
talking about the grand master normally
brand it means that there are there are
a couple of grand masters playing there
and everyone else who is not a grand
master has a chance to play those
grandmasters beat them and earn the
right to be
grandmasters themselves yes thank you
ilya there you go and after this we're
looking at the results from number one
round one that is
we have david brodsky beating josiah
stearman chris repka losing a big battle
for
probably the highest ranked players
playing so chris rapp got lost in a
fighting game against baloch
even park lost to joshua ruiz and the
last two was pretty eco-friendly draws
all the way
viktor matvishan drew against balaji da
gupati and kosyakovsky drew against ivan
shitko
so
with that out of the way
let's take a look at the i am section
oh wow section has had some quite a
couple of quite fighting chess games i
see the first the first pair of players
made a draw but then we have ellis lee
who lost the gabriella antonov jennifer
you made a draw against uh against
theater master ezra chambers who is also
my former teammate from webster
university uh then matthias marek
beat pedro rodriguez and finally aaron
grobinski beat julian police aaron is
also
my former teammate from webster and also
very nice guy and extremely strong
player and more about the upcoming
schedule
what we have for today
so today
we are having a double round
and
same day all day saturday a double round
11 a.m around four five p.m around five
while it continues on till the end uh
even in the last round that's actually
unique usually it's one round right or
actually it's one round
but in case of a playoff
there is going to be another match sorry
for the winners i do see that on monday
there is only one round and then there's
follows up with one so that's correct
right then
yeah two two last days one round each
yeah so let's look at the pairings for
the gm norm today we have josiah sterman
taking on ivan shitko balaji
vladimir belush against evan park
and bellows actually has just won
and we've got david brodsky against
chris rapcott which ended in a draw
so we've got a live couple of live games
going which one would you like to go to
elia uh so as far as i can tell we are
now
looking at a fairly interesting end game
between josiah steerman and ivan shitko
um
very very interesting uh
because white is clearly trying to win
holding an extra pawn here but you know
and and then games is kind of um you
know defensive capability of
capabilities of the side was you know
was missing material is usually quite
substantial especially since this can
probably even go into a rook in game so
i think here black can go knight e2 and
kind of force a rook in game but this
working game seems like it's probably
just it's just right because i guess you
could just trade yeah training the
second pawn yeah and the king is just
cut off which i guess is just deadly
even if the f-pawn is gone exactly this
is probably still lost yeah so in in
rook and games it's essential to have
all your pieces active meaning both
rooks and kings should be participating
and if if one one instance is not then
it's just it's usually just doomed
yes so this does not look good for ivan
shitko
um he did play knight e2 but
also he's low on time look at the clock
30 30 seconds yes 92 was just played is
it not is it not what we analyzed no
knight e2 it's uh the red move which
means it was played okay so knight t2 i
guess
you could consider other moves but the
knight f4 is kind of annoying i guess
the rule of thumb is in a winning
position you should simplify exactly so
you just take the knight go for the rook
and game with two extra pawns black king
is cut off should be a
fairly simple very simple one for white
yeah because if you start gambling in
some ways well
sometimes your king can get into trouble
yeah also here it's not quite clear how
black would make progress because yeah
you're just taking care of all the pawns
probably could still try something like
knight c3 although white still should be
close to winning yeah essentially just
trying to get the same rook and game
which is probably lost anyway yeah
um but in any case
probably bishop takes c2 takes king
takes g3 is the simplest way and
i have no doubts that josiah should be
able to find this with 40 minutes on the
clock
that's that's not not a difficult task
oh so we've got some messages
it's ilia yes it is indeed illya that is
me
so let's take a look
at some other games let's take a look at
um
victor castillo joshua where it says
motivation
let's take a look you mean
yes
yes
yes yes it's a long name so what's
exciting is that there were many many b3
games this one actually was one b3
and what is on a piece as we can see
yeah well why this down a piece but
there is some play let's say if it takes
i can just take on e6 on e6 there's a
piece right back there
is two pieces hanging
so you're just gonna lose it back so
that's unlikely to be a great choice
other than that there is this trick of
bishop takes c6 so if you just ignore me
i can take here
double attacking
okay so i guess i guess this was all
part of voice plan if you can go back a
couple of moves actually quite here is
how we reach this
point and yes it seems that it was
indeed
how
did both sides manage to cast so long
that's that's well let's go back from
the beginning shall we so b3 uh very
interesting like half of the games
played
was b3 either on move one move five or
move seven which is kind of
rare and interesting is this a
historical is it is it history well now
it's history but it was played
just a couple of hours ago oh okay okay
so
uh b3 d5 bishop g4 f3
which looks like a weird move but here
it tries to take advantage of this
bishop being misplaced
h4
f6 very unorthodox play here d4 this
feels like fish are random to me i don't
know about you ilya but i mean i feel
like f6 is the only movie you can make
because otherwise you just lose the
bishop so it's not yes so what ilia is
saying after e6
is g4 right and then but okay here we
can argue that black can try tricks like
bishop e7 for example
we should be seven although here
probably you can even just give it up
give this pawn up because i have this
double threat okay are we looking at the
chess game well we are going to look at
the chess game
i don't know what i'm saying is that
this doesn't seem like a chess game at
all oh it doesn't seem like it yeah well
something goes to e2 and move seven
right and
i never seen this ever again ever
because the king usually doesn't doesn't
leave the original square unless it
cancels well here
very unorthodox play by both sides f3 f6
played not something you should do ever
well in this case it's just five
in this case you had to because of g4
and h5 tracks
in real chess games the king goes to
e5
knight c3 bishop f7 queen d2 and here's
the castles on both sides okay yeah
h5 and
i guess you could claim that uh there's
some balance in the center with white
actually having a little pull on the
side
yeah white definitely has expanded more
on the on the king side here and uh
definitely has more space
on that side and in some ways i don't
know how would you
label this bishop is it a good bishop
bad bishop
it's uh
it's a bishop it's
not great because well it's a more of a
defensive bishop so whenever i look at
the piece i always determine its
relative's worth or its relative
strengths
by looking at its potential its
attacking potential so defending p
defensive piece is it's useful in a way
but it's still it doesn't it doesn't
allow you to apply pressure into your
opponent and essentially you win games
by pressuring your opponent constantly
and making them forcing them to make
mistakes and here when i see a piece of
bishop on f7 i i can't help it but i
believe that the bishop could could be
doing a better job on the contrary if
you look at the bishop on f1 why is
bishop on f1 it has a very clear goal it
can go to b5 it can go to h3 even and
apply a lot of pressure you know on both
sides
and it's very interesting like the
potential of the bishops right some of
them doesn't really have a future like
let's make it red because if i could
make it red that'd be great but
how to because because you don't know
that you're supposed to hold alt ctrl
and shift oh at the same time i mean i
did that a minute ago no but you're only
holding two but that's three oh okay
you're supposed to all right three all
three oh and it's the orange
how about these two okay so ctrl shift
yeah ctrl shift yes thank you
so this bishop on f7 really doesn't have
a bright future apart from defending
this pawn and this is just way too well
defended to be a target chess 96 we are
yes we are commentators both of us are
grand masters grand master danish
borussia messi
so knight h6 this is how it continued
knight before
which
is an interesting idea but no no it's
bishop before i move
i don't know why i thought it was
knight before anyways it could probably
come and wipe knight before it's not a
good idea it's probably not but you can
just get it out of the c3 would happen
knight would have to go back the knight
would have to leave
any case g4
now there's two bad pieces so
let me use my newly learned skills okay
oh yeah yeah so h6 and the bishop on f7
is bad so by now i i would say that
white has a slight bit of an edge but
also it's kind of difficult to make
progress because black doesn't really
have weaknesses outside of really
positioned pieces right yeah i mean
black actually is the one who has a
little bit of an extra center control
right so bishop g2 king b1 bishop b6
queen c1 this is a very hippo like play
i'm just trying to move away from this
bishop
and now d takes e5 as we're going to see
very soon is going to be a threat
so queen e7 is played
rook g1 knight f7 bishop h1 i guess
right preparing f4 yes although after f4
and then if black ever decides to play
e4 a completely like solidifying
structure in the center it's going to be
i feel like it's going to be a tough
task to make any kind of
progress anywhere
yeah and i have to be careful about it
just what you're saying maybe g5 isn't
that great because black could just wait
let's say play something like pass with
a6 unless
and
just wait for this idea five out of four
well you can go f5 i you attack my pawn
okay but [ __ ] take on i can take on
c3 yeah but what i was saying is that
maybe instead of playing four
immediately maybe white can start by
taking on e5 first and then
and then go f4 yeah this is this is
completely different it's actually very
close very similar to what happened in
the game right all right so let's fast
forward to what happened in the game g5
f4
captures captures the e pawn
takes takes d4 f5 now all kinds of
tactics ensue bishop takes
rook takes rook takes
takes bishop takes c6
just double attacking both
b takes f takes takes queen takes g4
because let's see what's going on well
why may have screwed up but black still
has a bad king so there's something to
play against oop still wrong click
but how it was a queen not not with the
queen on c1 white has to take
another okay so let's see how white
could improve this position my first
stop would be to bring the queen out and
i'm just going to take everything from
you
you do take pawns from me but
and then then they're going to rock
but first let me just go play rook f196
knight d6 i'm going to go on knight a4
and just get closer to your king i can i
can be mean and play knight b7
yeah okay
but i probably won't because i don't
have to yeah i mean it does start
looking a little bad there but if what
what how does that
well i'm not necessarily winning or
anything but at least your pieces are
bad quenching six yeah but i mean my
point is this is not this is this
doesn't look enough at all queen d6 i'm
not sure that you're winning anymore i
think i'm winning when you're winning
queen d6 yeah
yeah of course uh you're just in time
yeah this knight c5 because if i get
knight c5 in there i have some hopes of
course if you also had a five two which
is probably even easier mm-hmm why is a5
better because because i'm maintaining
control over the e4 square so i can
start pushing my past pawns and my next
move is literally just e4 e3 and you
know i start pushing the pawn yeah i
don't no longer have this pin going
it's not as good so what just happened
why did this i think it was just a
miscalculation and wise part like here
rook d1 is a very very cool intermediate
move taking away you know distracting
the g1 rook from protecting the pawn on
g4 so it's it's
white take on d1
there's probably queen takes a3 ideas
though yeah bishop is c three queen a3
so i guess that's why white didn't
didn't do it and then takes sticks no
you can't take on c3 first you have to
take on e6 first otherwise you're down
the piece yeah so it takes
quite a three
knight c3 rookie as opposed to six sorry
rookie six yeah g6
and that way maybe it's just deemed that
there's not enough compensation here so
what is missing and queen d7 well no it
is enough because no i think maybe not
queen d7 but maybe g5 because d7 is
going to run out to queen e7 leading to
yeah just mass trades
even that is not a simple ending
definitely yeah this is not nothing but
simple so maybe maybe that's what i
should have opted for because yeah some
g6 threats yeah and this bishop is a
monster and there's no opposition to it
right so it it just shows how good of uh
the plan white had in mind but messed up
the order and that was enough
for the higher rated player to take over
ticks
takes
player take over all right
it is true mattvision is 2510 and uh
ruiz is 2454. i was i was looking at the
titles as well but it seems that uh well
yeah there there's
that kind of victory a little bit yeah
so king b2
and just take on h5 and play with two
extra pawns
obviously there's some practical
difficulties here but i think in the end
of the day white does not have enough
counter play on the king's side because
of the snap in d6 so let me ask you this
um what would be your priority in this
position with black
as the one with the extra pawn well i
obviously i would like to well my the
goal for someone who is ahead is to use
the advantage right so in this case my
advantage is two extra pawns i would say
that the pawn on e5 is is
is further advanced and then it's you
know friend on h7 so i i would say that
i would focus i would try to focus
on promoting the e5 pawn while at the
same time trying to not fall
victim to white's you know counter play
on the king's side so maybe i'm not sure
if playing e4 immediately is a good idea
like if if if this was a
i mean it's quite to move now so let's
say white goes knight a4 and then i will
obviously take on d1 and taste thing and
just again take it obviously
but if i let's say yeah rook g1 then you
go e4 yeah because my point was i didn't
really want to play e4 while the rook is
still so maybe if we play around d2 for
white
instead i'm not sure if i want to go e4
because there's room d4 before right so
see
even though you're up plenty of material
it's very easy to slip up exactly it's
kind of easy to go to go wrong and fall
a full victim into the counter play i'm
not sure if this is enough enough of a
counter play to
get anything substantial for what but
definitely if
so since
black needs to
respect it i think yeah there's there's
a respect that needs to be given yeah um
actually i kind of like your knight b7
ideas although not right now because
then i could go knight e4 jarrett is
saying that maybe we should focus on the
h pawn instead of the e5 pawn and i
completely agree because yeah if the
rook if the white rook stays in the
d-files and definitely just for the
purpose of sole purpose of avoiding the
rookie for open war maybe we should just
move the queen away and push the h pawn
it looks you know like queen g6
yeah yeah all that said e4 was played
instead of taking interesting okay so
i feel like this might be a little bit
too rushed honestly rook before is there
and there's an idea as you mentioned
earlier so i feel like i feel like black
is kind of kind of um claiming that even
if rogue d4 before it is happening okay
we can actually just get a shot sorry d4
let's see queen takes h5
i'm just going to let before happens
wrong b4
so wait here yeah even though then c5
i was trying to make the point that here
black can just uh leave the a7 pawn as
isn't go king c8 and i just give it up
high decay on d7 and yeah i'll take on
a7 i'll i'll just be the lamb and right
follow yeah and then queen e5
just trying to centralize exactly and
instead of trying to protect the king
side just run away and then focus on the
persian the queen side the hsh5
i'm not so sure no no
yeah yeah okay i can all right a5 knight
b5
maybe and that's good for black right
because rocate
okay i'll try to move away uh-huh h4
oh there's queen h3 check so yeah
there's queen h3 oh it came b8
okay now i'll play a5
h3
h3n you you're almost oh i can i can
actually just go king b and trap your
rope here so what ilia is saying is h3
takes
here the rook is going to be trapster
king i don't even have to play straight
i can just go king babe or king v8 right
away yeah king v8
well
yes
but once again this is probably this is
probably unnecessary i think black has
something else in mind and that's as we
can see what d4 was playing
yeah so here let's see what what black
hat playing black is black is yeah black
and white
five a5 is uh
it's somewhat risky no because you're
sort of moving away with those guardian
pawns those guardian pawns are usually
there to protect your king you start
pushing them
and it becomes naked
although how can white really use them
i've been thinking about potential plans
here rocky 4 doesn't seem to be doing
much like rookie 4 we can just take
capture on h5 you can definitely can
just capture what if i go
absolutely not sengo b4 oh my god we did
realize something very important after
if i think if i was a major blunder can
you go back i think it was just a
blunder you see that right yeah
yeah rook takes d6 i think we you might
see wow
black not winning this game although
this is still it's still questionable
i'm not sure but why definitely as a
last resort i think it's a yeah it's a
great idea yeah okay
pontix all right let's calculate so
first off anyone who's watching we are
also watching the chat on twitch and on
youtube so if you have any questions for
eleanor or i
just ask away
and
i'm wondering
can we actually go for more here
as white
so queen b6 obviously we could force
some traits but i'm thinking of night
jumps yeah exactly so that's what i
think taking on d6 could be mistaken
because then white kind of escapes
perpetual
yeah queen takes c6
indeed enough queen d6 there's queen d7
so yeah blackboard but now an idea
exactly 95 now and this knight you see
this is this is kind of this is the kind
of a topic i i i teach my students this
is this is uh peace synergy queen
queen along with a knight is uh is a is
a big strength right so because they
supplement each other perfectly so and
this is in you know in this case
we can clearly see that you know the two
pieces work great with each other's
multiple threads but i'm not sure black
can deal with i honestly have meanwhile
breaking news aaron grobinski did win
his game nice very exciting game where
he showed some
deep knowledge of the hedgehog which
actually shocked me so i'll be very
excited to ask him
how did he feel while playing that
position
but coming back to this game 36 was
played um rook d6 was played and uh i
kind of ignored the clock but mattvision
was just low on time exactly that's
probably the reason for the blunder now
that's actually one of the big questions
i have
if you're low on time should you just
wait it out and say okay
if i flag i flag
but at least my move will be the
ultimate best
so cd happened queen b6 happened yeah
but honestly though
if you're if you're in a time scramble
then you definitely should try to
not over complicate the position
otherwise you're shooting yourself on
the foot
to calculate you need time right so
because
you know
so
i guess what you're saying is that
you're playing in a position with low
time
why create new problems for yourself
playing e4 and then making another pawn
move changing the whole structure
correct just just keep the structure
steady make sure that you well i suppose
there's a second time control which
gives an extra half an hour
you know
both sides would get extra half an hour
on their clock after reaching 40. so i
suppose that's what they should have
gone for instead yeah and they actually
reached the position we discussed and
this is scary for matrician especially
as the roles reverse
because uh he was the one attacking and
now he's defending correct yeah this i
mean i would i would hate my i would
hate my life here if i knew that i'm
winning and then and then suddenly
suddenly it's just such a drastic switch
especially you know tables have their
tables have flipped
uh i would say in white's favor even
even if this is practically still okay
for black i would say that uh in a time
pressure like like this one yes
not you know yeah and queen d7 actually
loses on the spot exactly to check yeah
check check
and then b6
and it's game over
i don't i don't even see how to defend
and queen 7 is quite a huge thought
maybe check and play e3 and pray no oh
check right yeah check on just that one
has to be played yeah so check just to
defend and attack no he can't go e3
because i have queen a check and queen
a7 i have one of your queens so
yeah so after k2 black will probably
have to make move the rook maybe to e6
even oh but no that loses anyway this is
yeah it's again check check and the
queen is hanging this looks lost for
black honestly can i play the very well
this is falling too so it's just too
many and again what you're saying the
queen and knight synergy
they're just too strong
um too many threats
against the king and the queen
king of somas position 28 yeah and
when i'm saying
keep your guardian pawns close to your
king i'm not joking that's the reason
actually black is lost
because white's king is safe
and unlike
black's gang
this is just losing
let's see so uh so victor has about
about well 15 seconds left let's see
what he can come up with here
but i'm i'm i'm fairly pessimistic for
black
queen c8 maybe it looks bad six i think
it's over i'll queen d6 that's so i can
take and go into an end game so we've
got a move rookie six was playing
six yeah okay six i thought was was
probably uh i mean i i i
kind of forgot about it but there's some
there's some checks coming up so here i
thought queen c7 check should be played
and then wait isn't this just winning
check check check and uh f6 yeah but
king will go to f8 but there is none of
six anyway ah so check this is what is
talking about check here
and what i spotted two is this knight f6
check
this is taboo because the queen is
hanging
and otherwise this is just gonna win why
the game but elia says king f8 is still
possible but in that case not f6 five
and we can f5
i think black actually may might be able
to defend this
because now the king knight takes this
king g8 and knight is trapped
[Music]
so it's still sharp although i'd rather
be white honestly even if white is not
better white can force a perpetual
anytime soon once so it's it's very
pleasant when when you always have have
an option of you know
just bailing yeah to opt out for a draw
yeah
so let's see if there's something even
better
screen c7
there
you could also capture on h7 actually
right just check check and capture h7
and just keep keep the pressure going
yeah this is probably objectively best
practically best
thing white can do
because it keeps all the same problems
for y for black
while not forcing things right so the
black's main problem here is
okay
besides the fact that their position is
hard the other the other main or major
issues that black has no time so you
know the more pieces there are on the
board the more un
unclear the position remains the harder
it will be for black to navigate yeah i
guess i would be wondering if e3 is a
best practical try and just trying to
give up the rook and yeah but i do think
that the h pawn is equally as strong as
the e pawn it's going to be funny if you
see the the four queens on the board
position
possibly yeah actually we have king e8
on the position
e8
so either he's going for this
and again so we talked about uh playing
this with black when you're trying to
um
meanwhile queen c is played by ruiz
although i don't know queen takes h7
might be even more practical but i guess
he thinks this is winning so why not
just go for that one so
what would you do you're on the winning
side you've got five minutes versus one
minute should you spend all your time to
find the right move well this is
probably a critical critical position i
would say that it's i would say that the
approach that the approach taken by rhys
is wrong because once again it's too
forceful and
unless he sees a forced way to win which
i i don't right now unless he sees like
the exact the clear way
how to finish the game then it's
definitely it is definitely a
practically unsound decision yeah this
is yeah sorry this is something like
that inertia that you get into that you
feel your opponent is so low on time
they're just going to lose but that in
the extra 30 seconds never happens
right because
black doesn't have to think here there's
no decision to be made there's only one
there's one only move for black you know
every time they have to make a move
which is which makes it very
straightforward they don't have to spend
anything
knight c7 was played interesting yes
which might be the move we missed
because it does look winning yeah
actually it is actually winning so we
have to give credit for yeah because
yeah he found
he found the winning move and didn't
have any doubt so if you see the winning
move
you know you're off the hook there's
nothing uh they can really say all right
how did we not see nancy sorry rook g6
and there's check
i guess we were a bit too focused on the
king
that's why we missed it
knight c7 queen g7 takes takes yeah and
this is just resigns because the error
cannot be saved
yeah
very impressive very impressive buries
you know
well he capitalized on his opponent's
misstep
um yeah his opponent's approach was yeah
just uh
a little bit you know
too optimistic for for a position where
it's it's still somewhat unclear yes
black was winning but you know um they
had to have to keep the position as safe
for for themselves as possible until
they reached the time control but as we
can see that wasn't the case and yeah
but victor resigns here
um yeah so congratulations to ruiz yeah
it's a big win
and a big turn of events because victor
was having a great position
sometimes yeah before
we go to the im sections let's see the
pairings for today
what we have we've got joshua postuma
winning against julian proleko
pedro rodriguez
losing to aaron grobinski in a very
exciting hedgehog
and uh that's one of those things that i
want to show to you earlier because
chuckling here it is it is actually
something
unusual
but uh let's take a look
let me pull up the games that are still
pending
let's uh go to this game
between antova gabriela and jennifer you
oh
wow
so
seconds for both ladies
and even though
white has
a compact structure she's sort of
paralyzed
she can't really move her queen
she is stuck defending both the h3 and
the g2 square i suppose g5 is coming
yeah g5 and i think that uh jennifer is
lying to play that move whoa yeah g4 is
coming too and it seems like west
position is going to collapse yeah and
after the pawn push
and uh
i can't help but say it's all about
peace activity like you remember
we talked about the difference between
the bishops
in that game between ruiz
and matrician where the h-1 bishop was
much much stronger is the same thing
this bishop on d6 is just way superior
to its counterpart on c1
which is partly the reason why black is
crushing here
i mean but but technically if you look
at this thing every single piece from
both sides we can clearly see why it's
why it's on a white species are on
defensive and it's just you know
eventually eventually get overwhelmed
when when you have no no activity when
you have only pieces that are defending
you you have to eventually have to
you're forced to make moves such as e4
just to survive yeah gabby actually is
making the right choice exactly of
trying to activate her bishop and maybe
even try to stifle this bishop on d6
but i have my ability to wait because
she's watching
foreign it was played although i don't
know yes g4 was played she rocked hg4
looks like it's just yeah and it is just
over as rook h4 is hard to see i mean
yeah but it's full of force because
black can take on the forward check take
an e4 with a check and just pick up a
lot of material on the way
take sticks
and there's rook h4 or bacon c2 as well
that's that's just takes takes and
rotations
the queen and that all she wrote
which one
well
i believe that this is
quite deadly
um
yeah
i think there's a little agony from
antova but yeah there's no question
about
white
just losing eventually
and
this is why i always say try to develop
all your pieces
now of course
this was forced into this situation
but
oftentimes that's why
in a lot of openings they put the bishop
out quickly to g5 or f4 so it can never
actually end up on c1 and an asari state
like this one
so queen hd was played bishop f4
and uh game was over
white resigned yeah and jennifer won a
very nice attacking game amazing against
gabriella
so
let's
take a look at the last remaining game
between tokyo genova and alice lee
which is whoa is a crazy game
and even though tokyo genova had a very
much dominating position with a free
attack for her atlas lee is fighting
backhand even though those knights are
bad they're good defenders mm-hmm yeah
an item f7 is seems to be an amazing
blocking piece kind of taking care of
the entire king side for black
and and now actually the united knight
on f7 is going to be ready to start
picking up poems have
if in case y decides to move away from
from that side of the board so actually
uh although probably objectively this is
still should be winning for white i
would say that black has very decent you
know decent chances here as both players
are you know running down wait actually
yeah they're both very low on time like
two minutes each but have they have they
passed i think they have past time
control already so
i'm not sure if they have time control
oh they don't is it just no it's just uh
it is just straight up
you have two minutes left and that's it
oh i thought it was going to be an extra
half an hour yeah both both both blocks
that those are the classic events
and then norm events usually it's just
one and a half hours and then it's done
which either you win or you lose
well uh yeah
sometimes things do get simple like that
who would have thought that is in chess
but yeah anyways rook e8 um
well but
what is white going to do and this is
one of those things that i also suffered
from when i was playing the white side
it's very hard to come up with a
constructive plan so why does that have
a pawn though right but you know
opponent having perfect peace energy
having bishop pair
um
i would so i'm not still still i'm not a
big fan of remover key it felt like a
vase it felt like black and probably
could but could have gone for more maybe
something like b4 could be
considered opening up the queen
queen f1 is going to be in the air after
this not to mention some neat little
cheapos like this
nice yeah and winning the rook but any
case that wasn't played
um
here as per what i remember
it's not a bad idea to play king b1 and
bishop b2 just to create a safe square
for the king although it might it may
not be as as useful because black can
play rocky eight and threaten with queen
e2 at any time so i think the the
white deciding to keep the key on c1
actually has a purpose basically meaning
that white doesn't want to deal with the
queen e2 threats and but having the
bishop in between and the last would
probably be a a you know a good idea in
my mind so rook f2 well even though it
defends the pawn i don't really think
alice lee is thinking of capturing that
because yeah if you capture an f6 you're
you're kind of helping out what's dark
squared bishop because you know the
fewer the amount of pawns in the
diagonal the stronger the bishop becomes
and you know by not capturing an f6
black is making a uh you know an effort
to to make sure the bishop doesn't
become a monster i'm actually wondering
if ellis lee is going to play knight e6
because after that the idea of rook see
it and doubling becomes available but
once again kind of renders the rook e8
move useless because you don't need well
but you have to play something yeah i
think at this point both players are
trying to be like overly cautious
because uh they're both really well on
time and they don't want to you know
commit and be wrong
you know about their you know if if
either side goes for some sharp
complications there's always a chance
that
they will be wrong
yeah but i think sometimes indecision is
just the wrong decision
in these cases you do have to make a
decision eventually
and queen e3 was also a non-committal
move as you just said exactly yeah so at
this point i think they're just moving
back and forth kind of trying to
although 25 was clever because she is
denying the c3 square
from bagan although although i have i
have some doubts about the usefulness of
the bishop bean and c3 maybe actually
maybe there is there is a point because
from c3 maybe the bishop will eventually
go to b4 and try to get to e7 or or what
not so i think there is actually a
point behind this this manure
so king me one you could still go
something like rook a8
um i'm actually starting to think about
like c4 ideas not right now but for
example like king b1
let's say black passes
you could even consider c4 because of
this pin
and you could try to create a pass pawn
here this looks very dangerous but i've
seen this line of play played by strong
players like ferugia
you're just creating another
um
weapon in this position and trying to
just create more chances although it
does give you more more things to worry
about right that's true yeah it's very
risky because the b-pawn becomes
weak however you have winning chances
because of it and but once again because
of non-committal approach from from both
sides we may not even see something that
has been played for a long time because
yeah both players seem to be
seem to be uh very cautious
in proceeding with aggressive responses
so yeah rook d2 again very cautious
queen a6 i feel we might just get some
sort of repetition because both sides
seem to be very hesitant
yeah i think if white wants to make
progress at this point they need to
commit with either maybe
move a bishop e2 or queen d3 and just
make stuff happen attack something
yeah and even even even if it kind of
you know uh uh transposes into some kind
of end game where black will take both
h6 and f6 which should be two so
is actually going for it
props for the fighting spirit network b8
i suppose will happen rook b and again
i'm well c4 is risky actually because
white can take a black and take on c4
yeah black would definitely go for the
sacrifice
you think i mean well it's not even
necessary but you could go for this and
this is always
very pleasant because as we can see the
king is very exposed
so queen takes f6 happened sorry
okay well this this is this is the kind
of the kind of progress that
white probably uh was looking for
because
now they
got rid of the opponent of six it's kind
of not waiting their bishop play right
or eventually if white ever manages to
win the pawn on e5 the bishop will
become super strong and also they manage
to win the opponent before i think this
is just lost i honestly feel like bucks
position is about to collapse
next move is bishop c4 and then white
can just easily double up on the f file
and apply enormous pressure against f7
knight it's still an eidorf i mean i
always feel like yes i'm winning yes i'm
winning but let's say again like this
bb-8 was played since the rook city like
i would even sacrifice or if bishop c4
still sacrificed this i think it's not
enough yeah well it might not be enough
but in a practical game it's not that
easy to actually claim
there should be
i i believe there should be an easy way
to uh you think this is just easily won
oregon big red yes it's the two of us
together how how are we we are excellent
dennis just came back from hungary and
i've been here so
i'm i'm actually dubious i i'm not sure
that this is like you are better
obviously but you still always have to
look out for some objectively i mean
there's always some practical issues but
i feel like in the long run if white is
slightly a little bit careful they
should be able to win this so okay
anyways rook b8 on the board
what's funny you can always lose a game
it's the same thing but on the other
side of the board
and
and meanwhile all the gm games are over
oh really what happened in the last game
so
in the last game
there was a win by balaji
against costco the game
was winning end game right yeah
yeah no it was the steerman game that we
thought was winning all right and
steerman actually won it
um
yep quite easily
not gonna go into details but
just manage to convert the extra pawns
um dagupati also had a fairly smooth
game against kosyakovsky
so
big day for white oh wow so many white
wins only a single draw between david
brodsky and chris rapka
but i think we should come back to this
game as this is still very exciting and
bishop c4 was played
right i don't see alice lee not
sacrificing on c4
i believe
that all talents these days
and she is reaching for a move
josh did win
i'm noticing yes he did yeah josh did
win
what do we have here i mean honestly i i
feel like roxy4 is probably objectively
the best choice for black because what
else if they don't do something
immediately then white has a very
straightforward plan right once again
the f file is got open up the bishop and
c4 is you know is going to be a problem
so if black doesn't take on c4 right now
then white may even decide to play rock
c5 and 40 seconds for ellis lee
and by the way um for all of you and
maybe even for elia ellis lee actually
had a great run in the american cup i
don't know if you've seen that place
yeah amazing chess and uh great
composure from the young competitor
she played knight e6 and uh i don't like
that move as much i think rook d7 is
probably about to happen and uh
it looks d7 i mean i can still capture
he can't capture but maybe i can
okay so instead of
d7 maybe i can begin with rook f2 and
then if net f4 there's there's some
capture on e5 that may or may not work
actually i think it works
rookie five yeah and you're pinning rook
f4 next yeah we just take c4 f4 so looks
like winning material you can't touch
this you can't touch this because of
this pin and it takes then rook takes f4
and that is probably all
that needs to be played yup that is just
decisive and i feel like e6 was a big
mistake i think anyone who has the
needed experience would capture
immediately on c4 and just hope for the
best
because uh even though
maybe you're lost but it's still very
difficult to push on something that's
true yeah nicer taking good care of the
uh yeah and the game is playing actually
some fine chess here
she's putting a lot of pressure after
was played nice yeah
i mean
very sound decision so far by uh taher
geneva you know
objectively i would say that she's she's
you know playing
very practical chats and in inside of of
you know time machine night the four was
played i think the game we may even see
the game
been over within the next couple of
moves if white finds rock takes e5 maybe
we can cheat a little bit and see if e5
works using the engine rook takes c5
rook takes c4 well i trust our little
engine running in our heads okay um i do
believe that rook five should be
winning rook takes queen take rook takes
f4 chess legion live thank you very much
for raiding with the party of 38 welcome
everyone here looking at the final game
of i am norm congress
between tahrir geneva and lee
white seems to be doing great but both
both players are very low on time and we
may see yeah brook takes e5 was
displayed by beckham
and yeah i think she just calculated and
made the decision okay i can go for this
and just wrap it up
well wait a second can i just go queen
c6 okay so ticks takes
queen c6
and i want to take here well it's just
long it's lost yeah because uh even
though my king is a little exposed it's
not exposed to vip's doing commentary
yes so when i take c5 and i guess just
move that 24 or 24 hours
we care about the c4 pawn yeah we don't
really care as long as we can hide the
king
and you'll be before this happened rook
afforded it happened and we've arranged
so we are reaching this position
so
yeah queen v6 i guess is there but the
queen d6 we have an intermediate move
rogue d5 which
should do the trick and you're having a
double attack going on on c4 and d6 and
yeah i think together did a good job
with this last part you never well
so far she's been doing very well
uh her decisions were spot on so for the
moment she is winning yeah she's
definitely she's definitely deserving to
win this game so far i'm gonna knock on
the wood
but uh well we're not really picking any
sides here
um but what we're seeing here is that uh
begin is
in the driver's seat queen d6 played but
i guess rugby five is not going to be a
difficult move yeah for white to find
what we never know
rook d5 queen takes spontaneous queen
this queen before after that but there
is seven
okay so here
queen b4 d7
or f7 server f7 or d7 even
okay so rook f7 king takes
yeah and some and just some mating at
time
king
g8 have maybe it's not that simple i
mean wait i can actually just go back so
take sticks here how about rook d7 but i
can just do this yeah and the queen of
six queen e1 right and queen e1 yeah
rook d1 roxy 2 takes yeah this should
still be winning i think yeah because i
can block in time
so rook d5 was played it's on the board
i mean b4 is played
so so far good job ilya we are doing a
fine job here uh kind of guessing all
the moves guessing all the tactics yes
yes yeah so so far we are very proud of
ourselves i think rook f7 will happen on
this f7 or rook d7 well why buy risk
that's true actually that's a good point
see that's that's that's a better the
better choice
you know being made by danish because
you rock if someone is
if you don't see a clear checkmate and
once again there's no need to to go for
it because you're not sure if you're
going to check that or not but rook d7
is simple it's straightforward it's
attacking the night where can the net go
pretty much nowhere because there's
always rook to seven if you're not
decided to leave
um
okay provides black with some
counterplay i believe yeah
nah actually now it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be enough kindy ii and then
followed by king c3
yeah king d2 here and then queen c3
was checkmate yeah this is and
yeah
so she's just not fearing any ghosts
doesn't even go for the lines v
suggested
yeah king d2 yeah okay
now i feel bad because i think this is
just way easier on the crime scheme of
things this is just
forward
you know there's no difference between
winning and winning moves as long as you
win the game that's that's a good point
but you see we are trying to we're
trying to become ideal players perfect
players that's true but
i'm not even sure
it is possible that rook d7 is
objectively the best but if b takes c4
wins that's good enough yeah it is it is
the last game of the day oregon pick
right yeah
so king d2
technique
queen b7 was played in b7 okay
i guess when d4 is coming up on yeah and
just rook the e8
when you start checkmate yeah and it's
just checkmate
check check
takes and it is mate
so let's see if it happens queen d4 has
played and yes the game is about to be
over this is
a threat very hard to deal with
so impressive game by toke genova
but there have been quite a few
impressive games um i'd say that
that game by jennifer you was pretty
good
and
but let's wait till this game finishes
so queen b4 king e2
there's some
last moves literally
yes
king e2
queen f8 and yeah this is just agony
rook d7 and uh there's just not enough
either way yeah if you have all your
pieces on the eighth it's unlikely to be
a miracle draw although
in neither of us you never know this
time we do not yeah okay the extra rook
yeah and uh this is just
going to be picked up
six yeah alice alice is trying her
very best to to over complicate things
but unfortunately it's just too much
material to uh to deal with yeah i think
this is a little bit about timing i
think she had the idea of sacrificing
the exchange
but she turned it wrong
she took it uh
took on c4 with the queen b4 idea hoping
that that's enough but probably she
should have taken on c4 immediately
although i do yeah you're right but it's
probably at that point it's probably uh
objectively still lost for black with
the best practice with chance being
exchange sacrifice but i feel like
black might have misplayed a bit earlier
yeah but sometimes all you can get is
practical chances true yeah
so rookie 8 25 is probably indie 5 is
probably
that's flashy though that is a flashy
movie finish too yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna flash flashly flashy leave rook
after yeah still winning because if you
capture check
and there is checkmate
and um
queen d5 did happen can she did happen
king aj did happen
yeah there is zero reason to play
rookies probably queen d6
is finished
h2 checks and let the chats begin okay
it's just
just a couple of checks at this point
you can distribute anything unless you
don't hang up a piece of whatever yeah
is flashy by the way rook h4 yeah that's
so nice that's very flashy if it takes
was it playback network was played okay
objectively yes practically the
strongest yeah rook f2
and just uh
taking away all these possible checks
from ellis lee
um but obviously it's agony at this
point g5 happened alice's yeah
i'm gonna make probably gonna make a
couple more moves and
the game will conclude yeah so
yeah these are tough moments when you're
on the defending side and you realize
that you're losing
then do you think it's the right time to
give up
um
this is this looks like this looks like
the right time to give up but uh you
know
in chess chess is a sport anything can
happen obviously and uh if if a player
believes that they have some object
object you know objective chances they
can keep playing for example in my mind
objective chances when the position
isn't clear i may i might be down on
material so that's why i like your idea
of sacrificing the exchange a couple of
moves earlier is because yes black is
going to be down material but it takes
it you know takes skill and it takes you
know
precision for for for your opponent to
beat you still but here you know the
advantage is just so big that it's uh
you know
yeah there they still have to be some
live and opposite life in the position
in order for you to
when meanwhile queen before king j8 was
played
but here there's just not much left and
sometimes like we feel like fighting is
great but
sometimes you expend some nervous energy
yourself
even continuing
um i'm not against
playing positions where and the game is
and now
after queen f6 the trade is imminent and
that will be probably practically over
not that it wasn't before
but uh yeah i think there's the right
time of giving in or giving up sometimes
you don't give up because i just can't
get myself to do so even though i know
i'm lost says oregon big red and that
there's definitely some
some truth in that and some i i
understand where you're coming from um
but obviously uh in the light of you
playing against somebody someone who's
as strong or even stronger than you are
i think it makes perfect sense to give
your opponent some give you credit and
uh and and uh
put down your weapons well it's not
really about that so i'm i kind of on
the side that if you see some chances
play on
but if you exhausted all your chances
sometimes
you're just doing a disservice to
yourself for sure yeah because of your
self energy yeah you're kind of sapping
away your own energy and there's still a
lot of rounds to go
yeah i always managed to win the pawn
but yeah yeah but it's still just not
enough if i don't see people give up
yeah well i mean if your position is
lost or lost
then sure
but if you see tricks again that's fine
okay so in a minute we are going to have
josh postuma for an interview
for his win
against julian proleko
so um
all right so let's stick around
meanwhile at this moment
yeah so let's let's see
i think uh alice lee might
give
in
no no no
she's still fighting she's playing which
is of course admirable
uh that she has that fighting spirit
rook takes
takes unfortunately here it's highly
unlikely is that yeah like
yeah it's not just the extra rook but
the c pawn
and that was enough
for alice lee and that's quite a nice
win by tokyo genova
in the middle game i felt she had an
amazing position it did get complicated
but
amelia how did you like her handling of
the middle game i i'm late part yeah i
mean i it seems
it seems pro it seemed very practical so
i i would say that her channel made the
best practical decisions possible with
little time she had and and and you know
it paid off she she got a very nice
position that was opening where she was
you know objectively winning and then
you know she did everything right in a
you know instead of time pressure all
right so we've got postuma in
so
is happening in a moment
and as
possuma joshua took down
uh julian proleko
all right so as uh joshua is setting up
uh we're going to take a look at the
first couple of moves and i'm gonna stop
at move number two hello joshua hello
there dennis so move two were you
surprised to see this by julian yes i
was i was this was not in my uh like
preparation at all he normally plays d5
and you know normal like queen's gambit
decline type stuff
uh i've played this with black before
but i have never
played it with white not even online so
what was your thought process okay b5
this is new to me or never really phased
before
yeah i was uh i was out of my comfort
zone a bit
because i again i've played it with
black but it's been a couple of years
and i'm a little foggy on the theory but
i figured it's it's easy enough to play
for white it's just a you know king's
indian attack setup basically and uh i
might not get a big advantage but i
should get a reasonable position so it
continued with bishop g2
castles dc so you're kind of continuing
with the king's indian style right
bishop e7 e4 d6 but now you're doing
a bit of a switcheroo instead of going
for the usual king's indian attack you
throw in a4 how did that come by or you
knew this idea um
well i
i thought this would be a good time to
do it if i was going to do it because if
i gave black the chance to go knight b
to d7
then they'll you know after rook takes
a8 they'll always be able to take back
with the queen then the idea is no
longer good right so this is what joshua
is talking about yes so i thought if i
was going to go a4 i should do it right
away and i you know i thought i might
get him to weaken some squares like
weaken the c4 square if he pushes
forward
um
you know i thought after the trade
putting his bishop in the corner might
be
you know a poor place for it yeah and
probably had to go b4 here yeah just to
get a better grip here
because a6 and uh you found a very nice
plan here
of sort of provoking this v-pawn to move
so
knight to a3 was part of your knowledge
or
yeah well i've i've had somebody play
this idea on me before
so that's kind of where i i have seen it
learning from fast experience yes yes
and i lost that game
so i yeah i do think i learned from that
and remembered this plan
and so far anything that catches your
eye that you felt was interesting um no
not really this was all expected until
this moment i i was actually thinking
you might take back with the pawn
instead of the knight
i i don't know what you think of that
well
i kind of don't like this bishop stuck
on it and i assume that julian also
didn't want that bishop to be sort of
stuck there
on the other hand i kind of get your
idea because maybe you can go with c5
and yes i get a bad bishop but you can't
really pester my pawns that much yeah
and i was wondering how bad g6 would be
if he was worried about me putting a
knight into the f uh
that's reasonable because there's no
real way for you to actually right
there's no knight g4 or anything
probably you still have a little pull
because these pawns are a little bit
weak right and the bishop is misplaced
so i think you're a little bit better
but nothing like spectacular
so knight takes e5
queen a1 knight d7 queen a5
b3
yeah that move surprised me
and for for a moment i got really
worried because the first thing i
calculated of course was if i take on b3
knight c5 comes and
he's getting his pawn back my pawn
structure is destroyed this is not good
right um but you know then i realized i
can just go c3 and i feel like the the
pawn on b3 is even more overextended
than it was before
and unless he has some concrete way to
take advantage of like the d3 pawn
i i thought i could very likely just win
the pawn eventually yeah and bishop e3 i
actually like your move i know that the
computer isn't favoring it but you keep
keeping the position compact and uh
just keeping the tension which is
oftentimes more important in a better
position than to just simplify because
it also simplifies the defensive tasks
yeah i was told i was supposed to go
knight takes b6
um
yeah and i was curious after knight
takes b6 queen b5 uh and like queen d5
you know what's the
what's the path to an advantage for
white
yeah knight d4 would be a little sad
not a discovery so probably you could
take yeah bishop bishop takes
knight d4
okay yeah you could go knight d4 and
you're threatening to take and win the
pawn and c5 is just not in time right i
think this is just very pleasant for you
from strategical perspective i see
uh one other thing that i i wanted to
maybe comment on instead of bishop e3
um one thing i was thinking about was
queen b5 right now
this was my original plan but then i
realized he would uh he could take on c4
pawn takes and then he could take on f3
bishop takes and then knight e5 oh nice
tactics yeah
i can take the knight but then queen
takes d2 and then you know this is bad
yeah it's it's suddenly shifting i can't
save the b2 pawn right so i realized the
bishop on d2 was like a tactical
liability and you know that's i mean the
main reason i went bishop e3 yeah and
actually that's why i kind of like this
move more than like the engine tries to
hit on it like you are making sure that
there's no weaknesses left right so
takes takes knight b6 queen b5
and you're winning the pawn although i
do admit i was looking at the position
and felt that this ending
is tricky
like you have the extra pawn but somehow
julian always had some little tricks
yeah yeah i i feel like i did a very
poor job of getting my queen side
majority going whereas he did a very
good job of getting his kingside
majority going and um i wouldn't be
surprised if the engine shows my
advantage totally went away um or
largely went away over the next 10 moves
it's actually not easy because just
pushing the pawn creates a weakness
right so it's not that it's too trivial
the moves actually what the computer
says is somewhat nonsensical
um here
f3
king d3 then h3 it's not that we're
really trying to play g4 here
so even though white does have the extra
pawn but
is that really the winning plan i don't
think so
yeah it i guess it makes sense in that
we're going to go b4 eventually and we
don't want our pawns to be hanging on
the second rank yeah and we don't want
them all getting fixed on dark squares
yes i guess maybe that's the point i was
wondering before i started to bring up
the king um had should i have just gone
knight c1 and knight c1 and you know
tried to well without the help of the
king get the pawns but there's possibly
some rook a5 c4
c4 rook a4
okay
yeah maybe that's an idea
yeah i think it might have gone better
than the game did
anyways
knight c1 c4
e5 and
yeah
the advantage is sort of dissipating a
little bit but you know an extra pawn is
still an extra pawn
so g4 were there any moment you felt
like oh it's slipping a little
already yeah i was getting kind of
frustrated and you can see i'm also very
low on time
and i was actually thinking at this
point the game was likely going to be a
draw
so king e2 bishop c5 knight c2
and it turns out that takes takes e4
would have been better
and just bring the king and because of
the strength of this bishop right it's
uh very difficult to convert but julian
played f4
pawn takes yeah
seems very wrong yeah because you're
putting the pawn on the same color of
your bishop yeah and it's just going to
be an extra weakness
takes takes knight e1
knight d3 g3
and uh yeah you're just basically
picking up although b4 was
inaccurate right here but
i was just supposed to go c5 right away
c5 i was trying to decide between those
two moves but i thought uh pawn takes b6
c4
this looked very good but i thought b4
was better but oh i must have missed
something so you were considering both
of those i was considering both okay i
didn't have much time to consider both
but um well yeah sometimes you just have
to choose especially in a long time yeah
so i wonder what his uh his drawing uh
like the king had to
walk over so that was the idea just to
give it up
um
yeah but i mean that's not an easy
move to find especially on low time
right
so c5 bishop d but this is already
losing because you're getting your
knight in
takes
here
now i did think instead of bishop e7
like
you know maybe the one thing he could
try is king e6 or something trying to
get the king active okay um you know i i
feel like at this point he he
kind of played passively when maybe king
e6 would have been a better better yeah
although objectively i hear your name
sure so f4
knight b4 takes and yeah there's just
too many of those pawns and it's just
amazing and thankfully i have this and
thankfully i know my my king and pawn
versus king
so nice technical blend by you
um
probably you could have been a bit more
accurate right earlier but
apart from that
i think it was a nice performance well
thank you so good luck and uh keep on
rolling all right we'll do it thanks for
having me so we'll be back in a minute
with the results of the grand master
section
and the international
master section
so in the gm section josiah stearman won
against ivan shitko
in that end game
balaji dagupati again another endgame
winning against kostya kavutsky in a
taiman of where kavutski sacrificed the
pawn but really never got any
compensation for it or quite enough
joshua ruiz and we have elia back so
what were your impressions of the last
three games
i mean you haven't seen the david
brodsky one versus rapco it was just a
draw valve thought drop but about
the games between joshua and victor
mattvision and the values game um well
i i did actually see the final position
of broski versus replica and it seemed
like they had a fighting draw by move 39
but other games yeah i see anything can
happen you know the tables have turned
in multiple games and uh and we see an
up you know an upset and and and uh um
ruiz versus motivation and uh
haven't i haven't seen bellows versus
power game but i heard it's uh i mean i
have sorry johnson showed me the game
and uh yeah it was definitely very nice
by vladimir um other games also you know
free of compromise not free of
compromises and uh you know
very exciting stuff i hope that players
you know
keep showing up the same performance so
now we have the i am section results
um where
which wasn't really
such a big win for whites like in the gm
section which was a sweep
here uh joshua as he just was here
showing us his very nice win against
julian proleko and even though julian
fought back
he couldn't quite save this game
and joshua posted a nice win pedro
rodriguez lost against aaron grobinski
which unfortunately we couldn't hear
from aaron but if i get the chance i
will ask him about that very particular
hedgehog with a pawn on e5
instead of e6 which is unusual and i'm
not going to get into big details but
usually you have the pawn on e6 and upon
on e5 it's something i want to
investigate in a later moment ezra
chambers drew against matias marek
lost
a game a very painful game against
jennifer you it looked kind of fine
for anto until it kind of didn't as the
attack by jennifer you just broke
through and
gabriella's bishop on c1 was just not
able to withstand the pressure and sort
of the
game of the day if you're talking the im
section i believe that
bagam had a very nice a game against
ellis lee she had a very nice attack
they kind of ran out of steam
but
towards the end part which is actually
one of the most important parts of a
chess game where you still fight in a
middle game you still have to find some
good plans and beg him did
and
one in style
so these are the results that we have
from the gm and i am sections
and i really hope you guys enjoyed
watching
this one with me grandmaster elia nizhny
dennis borish and but stick around
because on twitch there will be a little
bit of a gaming going on
but for all of you watching on youtube
thank you for tuning in
and and also don't forget tomorrow i'll
be back with dorsa dark shani
and i won't
we'll see you next time
all right
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited